100 km sono una distanza molto ridotta
si pensa tele percorriamo con frequenza
e percorriamo senza particolare
coinvolgimento apprensione in fondo sono
a distanza che ci separa da bergamo dove
ci troviamo ad esempio a verona però se
questi stessi centro insignificanti km
invece di lasciarli in orizzontale nella
banale bidimensionalità nella quale
viviamo li votiamo in verticale
questi stessi insignificanti 100 km ci
portano alle soglie dello spazio lo
spazio così ostile inarrivabile si trova
solamente a 100 chilometri sopra nostre
teste e questo il primo motivo per il
quale mi piacerebbe oggi convincervi di
quanto sia importante che iniziate a
interessarvi allo spazio non vi
interessa lo spazio beh allora
cominciamo a dirci così ci capiamo che
se non ci fosse l'esplorazione spaziale
se non ci fosse stata oggi voi non
avreste il notebook non avreste il latte
in polvere non avreste le luci led non
avresti pannelli solari ad alta
efficienza non avreste materasso in
lattice non avresti nemmeno la
fotocamera sul cellulare non avreste la
navigazione gps non avreste le cuffie
senza fili non avreste il depuratore per
l'acqua e neanche il termometro
all'infrarosso non avreste nemmeno la
frutta disidratata
battute a parte decine e decine di
prodotti e di tecnologie che usiamo
quotidianamente
provengo dell'esplorazione spaziale
l'esplorazione spaziale che ha avuto una
prima stagione straordinaria
diciamo fra gli anni sessanta fine anni
80 la stagione fatta molta di moda
politica di nazioni che si guardavano in
cagnesco una nazione che una stagione
che definisco la stagione degli
ingegneri e io sono ingegneri che mi
posso parlare male degli ingegneri una
stagione la cui agenda ma soprattutto i
cui metodi erano basate su un approccio
scientifico
tecnico ribadisco ingegneristico
oggi invece a meno che non abbiate
vissuto un portiere una caverna vi
sarete accorti che siamo entrati in una
nuova stagione spaziale diciamo di space
economy una stagione molto intensa fatta
di grandi investimenti sempre più di
aziende private non solo più in azione
questa nuova stagione e la stagione
delle emozioni lo spazio ha cambiato
linguaggio e sta cominciando a parlarci
alle emozioni con un modo molto più
chiaro molto più facile
non passa giorno che signori come questi
the blue origin virgin galactic space ex
si contendano e copertine di mezzo mondo
per tenerci aggiornati sugli ultimi
raggiungimenti del nuovo business del
turismo spaziale un business che si
occupa di portare non più astronauti
professionisti ma privati cittadini
certo per ora molto benestante portare
in orbita e questo è un business che fa
delle emozioni della aspirazione delle
leve potentissime e credo che qualcuno
di voi dove fa qualche esempio magari
abbia visto l'ultimo superbowl super
bowl è più grande programma televisivo
sportivo al mondo in mezzo alle
pubblicità di coca cola mike general
motors c'è stato lo spot di una missione
spaziale ispiration four quattro privati
cittadini peraltro conclusa proprio in
questi giorni portati in orbita ma vi
invito a guardare con lo spot la musica
le fotografie le immagini assolutamente
di grandissimo coinvolgimento con il
linguaggio puramente cinematografico
oppure che dire di di ormoni di un nulla
non mi sono ancora più ambiziosa farà
l'orbita attorno allo spazio alla luna e
la navicella otto posti tutti gli otto
posti sono stati acquistati da un
miliardario giapponese che oltre a se
stesso per solamente lui non rimane a
casa dopo che ha pagato porterà con sé 7
creativi che per arte cultura età
disciplina molto diversi fra di loro la
cui finalità è riportare a noi in terra
da un'avventura così indescrivibile
altrimenti il ritratto più elegante e
coinvolgente affascinante proprio per
noi che siamo rimasti in terra e
l'utilizzo delle mozioni giusto per
capirci non è una formata una logica
marketing sia ben chiaro c'è un'altra
grande area di attività in questa nuova
seconda stagione della spessa economy
che quella di viaggi interplanetari a
lunga distanza quelli che passano la
mula luna e se lasciano le spalle che
vanno ad esempio su marte e questi sono
viaggi pensati per astronauti
professionisti non certo per per altri
cittadini giusto per capirci andare su
marte vuol dire fare nove mesi di
viaggio in un velivolo grande più o meno
con un autobus restare due anni in un
pianeta molto inospitale e al successivo
incrocio orbitale riprendere l'autobus
per nove mesi
progettare una missione di questo tipo
oggi va rivolto a professionisti
richiede una considerazione di aspetti
emozionali
psicologici motivazionali vedere
l'astronauta assolutamente come un
essere senziente con un grandissimo
strato emotivo e oggi di questo tipo di
progettualità e proprio al centro
dell'agenda del tanto importante
considerare le mozioni astronauti quanto
la quantità di carburante da imbarcare
il disegno del paracadute che rallenta
durante la marta già
lo spazio quindi parlandoci sempre più
attraverso le emozioni e quindi
cambiando il linguaggio che
fortunatamente voi non siete tutti
ingegneri e quindi per fortuna per foto
mafiosa dei genieri se ben chiaro
abbiamo l'introduzione gustavo
linguaggio che ci permette di entrare
molto più facilmente in contatto e
capire quello stia succedendo e ad
esempio il primo movimento che possiamo
fare senza abbandonare la serie state
tranquilli
guardando quello che succede allo spazio
riusciamo a cambiare il nostro punto di
vista noi purtroppo in terra siamo molto
abituati non ce ne accorgiamo ha creato
la nostra bolla molto faziosa molto
divisi vano ce ne accorgiamo lo spazio
ci aiuta molto a cambiare questo punto
di vista il fatto che cambi il suo
linguaggio
ce lo rende assolutamente fruibile e
quello che vedrete sempre di più la
scienza resterà impreciso libera
esplorazione spaziale ma diventerà
sempre più
un'infrastruttura nascosto un po come
fosse il ferro nel calcestruzzo vi
faccio questo esempio
quasi nessuno di voi io per primo sa
come funziona il microprocessore come
funziona un hard disk però tutti noi per
diletto per lavoro per passione passiamo
le giornate intere sul computer e
riversiamo il meglio di noi su questo
oggetto cui intimo funzionamento
ovviamente ci sfugge lo spazio sempre
più arriverà a questo tipo di dialogo
con noi e questo è fondamentale perché
lo spazio è un luogo di un'ispirazione
potentissima che mi permette di
condividere con voi perché volendo una
ricaduta già quotidiana già oggi vedete
in orbita
c'è una scienza cioè la disciplina sia
machine man factor che aiuta a gestire
capire come si comporta un essere umano
ad alta quota in orbita e quello che
affascinante è che una scienza che tiene
assieme gli aspetti biometrici
antropometrici fisiologici del corpo
umano ma in maniera indissolubile tiene
in considerazione gli aspetti emotivi di
stress di motivazione ed è un unico
corpo un'unica scienza che permette la
riuscita della vita in orbita ad oggi
questo è una potentissima ispirazione
persone possiamo fare un traslato molto
aderente molto potente perché lo stesso
possiamo fare fra di noi
adottando un approccio empatico
cominciando perde l'abitudine per la
quale ogni interazione che abbiamo col
capo il collega al figlio il cliente e
un'interazione ma ci abituiamo portare
in dote a portare l'abitudine che
attorno a quell'interazione c'è
un'emozione uno stato d'animo una
emotività e questo ci renderà molto più
efficaci molto più potenti nella nostra
vita assolutamente in terra
lo spazio quindi vedete che ci porta le
tecnologie migliori e sorprendentemente
vicino ed è un elemento di ispirazione
raffinatissima potentissima estremamente
concreta però secondo me c'è ancora
qualcuno di voi particolarmente
difficile a convincere al quale non
basta ancora tutto questo allora vediamo
di convincerlo e ricordandoci che
l'umanità oggi entrata in una fase di
costruzione di una nuova democrazia
spaziale
mi spiego fino a qualche anno fa attorno
alla terra in orbita attorno allo spazio
non è che ci fosse molto
ogni tanto passava un satellite russo
ogni tanto passava un satellite
americano
oggi vi ho ricordato come si stia
pensando di investimenti progetti
ambizioni oggetti e quindi diventato sta
mettendo necessario costruire un corpus
normativo che regoli quello che succede
nello spazio che non è più vuoto come
siano pochi anni fa
e giusto per evitarvi il dubbio che sta
parlando in star trek sappiate che ci
sono già degli enti che stanno gettando
le basi giuridiche per normare il
diritto di sfruttamento minerario nella
luna la gestione di un danno che un
satellite di terzi fa a una nazione un
privato la giurisdizione su un pianeta
come marte se io arrivo su marte metto
la bandiera un sito valeria non è che
marte diventa mia e tutte queste
dinamiche in terra se ci pensate sono
ampiamente normate adesso dobbiamo fare
nello spazio e perché vi riguarda ci
riguarda perché
le i principi della democrazia da
duemila anni ci impongono come cittadini
di informarci avere un'opinione essere
d'accordo sostenere contestare lo stesso
adesso è arrivato il momento di far lo
stesso nello spazio farlo noi
trasmetterlo alle generazioni
immediatamente successive perché non ne
sappiate che non è così lontano momento
nel quale andrete a votare
un partito un politico anche alla luce
dell'agenda spaziale questo partito avrà
e questa gente avrà una forte ricaduta
sulla vita vostra è sicuramente dei
vostri figli
lo spazio quindi avete capito che è
impossibile continuare ignorarlo e
portato le tecnologia è
sorprendentemente vicino e verona lassù
e poi è portatore di una grandissima
capacità di ispirazione alla fine spero
che avevi convinto che lo spazio è
straordinariamente vicino e
straordinariamente emozionante grazie
mille
[Applauso]